I am ernesto zedillo director the Yale
Center for the Study of globalization
thanks for being with us this afternoon
well Tom Friedman Tom Friedman is not
yet 50 years old and I think you're not
50 yet right on I think he will be 15
July right and I think I do not
exaggerate when I say that tom is a one
of the greatest journalists aforetime as
you know tom is the foreign affairs
columnist of the New York Times a
position that i think has been held only
by four people before Tom and this
column has been around for almost 50
years I think it is fair to say that the
Tom started he's a brilliant career many
years ago I guess around 35 years ago
when in his a high school newspaper he
groped a little report on a lecture
given by an unknown Israel in general at
the University of Minnesota out of all
places that general was the present
Prime Minister of Israel so he had a you
know a good a good vision since then tom
has been all over the world but very
especially he has been a very careful
close observer of the Middle East you
know that twice a week in a little bit
more than 700 words he put forward ideas
with extraordinary lucidity and
sometimes he put forward even both
diplomatic initiatives as we did
last year i think we couldn't have a
better moment to have with us Tom
Friedman I don't have to explain why
this is a very special moment for this
country for humanity at large and I
think we are very lucky to have Tom
Friedman with us today who will deliver
a talk for half an hour but he has told
me that more than giving a lecture he
wants to answer questions from our
students are no professors tomm welcome
home again thank you
thank you very much this this room
though proves that if you get a small
enough room you know you can sell it out
and but my greetings to people i know
are in overflow rooms and it's great to
be here this afternoon for the
globalization center and to be hosted by
two of old and dear friends nyan shonda
and ernesto zedillo Ernesto and I met at
probably his darkest one of his darkest
moments and one of my first forays is
foreign affairs columnist for the new
york times and i took over the column in
december 1995 arm right when the mexican
peso crashed and i had never been to
mexico and decided as one of my first
trips i was going to go down there and I
arranged for an interview with the new
president of mexico and went to their
white house and i'll never forget this
as long as i live was
I wasn't going to bring up that part
Ernesto but I never they the guards let
us in and directed us up to the
president's office and his secretary
directed us to his office in America we
sort of went through a halt and went
through another hall and went through
another hall and um I came upon the
President of Mexico and he was all alone
in his office listening to Tchaikovsky's
1812 overture hey and uh it was uh it
was truly a powerful scene in our
discussion was a powerful discussion
which had a lasting impression on me and
Mexico is so much better off for his
term as president and I'm glad to see
how successful he has been and that he's
here now at Yale because I know Yale be
better off as well so i Nesta thank you
for having me here I'm going to talk
today about kind of the journey I've
been on since nine eleven and my
apologies to any other strategy students
who are here who may have heard part of
this talk that I did for the strategic
the strategy course a few months back
I'm actually been besides writing my
column been working on a documentary for
the discovery channel ah that will air
on March 26 I've had a crew of with of
the discovery channel with me in my
reporting for the last six months which
has been an experience for me in and of
itself and the documentary is called
searching for the bottom of 911 and
which has been my own personal journey
since September 11 and the crew has been
with me from Indonesia to Saudi Arabia
to Dubai to Qatar to Bahrain to Egypt to
yesterday and Belgium where I returned
from last night where we were meeting
with Belgian Muslim leaders in Antwerp
and in Brussels um and and basically
what what this journey has been about in
searching for the roots of 911 is really
to try to answer one
fundamental question and that question
is who were those guys who were those
guys who were those 19 young men who
boarded those four aircraft on September
11 and flew to into the World Trade
Center they went into the Pentagon and
one into a field in Pennsylvania who
were those guys because I felt until
unless I can answer that question for
myself I won't feel safe I don't think
my country will feel safe I I really
need to understand who these people were
and what impelled them to do what they
did on that day which was such a
bursting of the frontiers of
civilization that um to this day I
sometimes finding myself looking at the
footage of the event and still not
believing it actually happened now i
believe the hijackers um fall into three
three categories basically but the first
category are the leaders and the
conceptualize errs of the event and that
is to people in particular Osama bin
Laden and Ayman Zawahiri Ayman Zawahiri
we haven't heard much about he is the
leader and founder of Islamic Jihad and
in many ways believed to be the real
brains behind 911 I'm gonna ask you guys
to take a break for a little bit thanks
and bin Laden in zya is how a hurry um i
would call islam o Lennon asst because
uh they are truly at heart um a Leninist
they are two men who I believed in many
ways d spiritualize dis LOM and really
converted it from their point of view
into a political ideology in another age
in another place had they been at Yale
in the 60s they would have been
Trotskyites or Marxist these are men
given to utopian solutions to the
building of the kingdom of God on earth
only
the kingdom that they wanted to
construct was not one built on class
like marks but not one built on race
like Hitler it was one built on a
religion and they are in a very classic
way utopian cult leaders if you want to
understand them study David Koresh study
Charles Manson study omron chiquillo in
Japan and so at the very top of this
pyramid you have the guys with the
utopian ideology but to carry out and
execute their utopianism they needed
foot soldiers and this brings us to the
boys of 911 now the boys of 911 fell
into themselves two groups one group i
call the saudis and one group I call the
Europeans and these are two very
different groups now the Saudis were the
muscle guys they were the guys in the
back of the plane and they come from a
vast pool of young men in Saudi Arabia
whom I call the sitting around guys the
sitting around guys because there are
thousands upon thousands of these young
men sitting around in Saudi Arabia and
you can see them on any Thursday night
driving up and down the corniche in
Jeddah now that the force the kind of
cement mixer that produces these sitting
around guys is what i call the wheel of
bin Laden ISM the wheel of bin Laden ISM
is made up of three basic components the
first is autocratic anti-democratic
regimes the Arab League had a summit or
has it summit coming up this year March
25th in Bahrain 22 nations will be
represented not a single one will be
represented by a leader elected in a
free and fair election there is no
region in the world not sub-saharan
Africa not Latin America not Central
Asia not East Asia not Eastern Europe
where you could have a regional summit
and not a single leader present would
have been elected in a free and fair
election that's the top of the wheel of
bin Laden because these leaders are
basically illegitimate in order to in
effect by legitimacy what they do is
empower fund in a noite what i call
aunty modernist religious leaders and
educators these anti modernists then
basically produce young generations of
people unprepared for the most part for
modernity to really master the modern
world that produces poverty and
backwardness that reinforces the
autocracy the awkward part aqua syrian
forces the anti modernist religious
education the anti modernism reinforces
poverty and the wheel of bin laden just
goes around and around like a big cement
mixer churning out sittin around people
when i was in saudi arabia last year
doing the interview with crown prince
abdullah thats audis had given me a
driver and a minder to keep you know to
protect me and but during the time we
were together over nine days we actually
got to know each other and one of them
the the younger hull dune said to me one
day just apropos of nothing he said you
know mr. tom the problem here in saudi
arabia is it's not islam the problem
here is that in every house there are
two or three young people not working
they go to the mosque preachers fill
their heads with crazy ideas and that
mr. tom is the problem and that i
believe really is a big part of the
problem now this problem was diagnosed
in another way my we love bin Laden ism
by the Arab human development report a
remarkable document produced by 25
extremely courageous Arab economists and
sociologists released last year by UNDP
which has two fundamental question why
is the Arab region so lagging behind the
rest of the world why is it that the 22
states of the Arab world
do not have a combined gdp equal to that
of Spain why is it that Greece last year
translated more books from english to
greek than the entire Arab world
combined translated from English to
Arabic why is it that you have a such a
huge illiteracy rate among women in the
Arab world and the conclusion of the
Arab human development report was very
simple it correspond adre flee to the
spokes of my wheel of bin Laden ISM they
concluded it was because of a deficit of
freedom a deficit of women's empowerment
and a deficit of modern education and
that really is the engine as I say
manufacturing sitting around people
sitting around people who end up
basically being drafted to projects like
Afghanistan some drift into more radical
groups some into yet more radical groups
and some drifted into the rolodex of
Osama bin Laden and he tapped them late
in the plot of 911 to join this project
but as I said there's another group of
hijackers and these people were
assembled they did not organically come
together the second group i called the
europeans i called them the europeans
because there is a striking fact that
cries out from the year of 911 and
that's that Mohamed Atta shukaku jar the
key plotters and pilots of 911 the
Hamburg cell what is so striking about
them is that not a single one of them
left home a Muslim radical every one of
them was radicalized in Europe in a
European mosque or a European prayer
group every one of them was radicalized
in their encounter with the West now
this isn't just true of the boys of 911
mr. moussaoui the gentleman out in
Minnesota who wanted to learn to fly
747s but not
and them son of a Tunisian mother
radicalized in a French mosque mr. Shah
the terrible man who plotted the murder
of Danny pearl Pakistani from London
radicalized at a British mosque mr. Reid
the gentleman who couldn't blow up his
own tennis shoes a Jamaican immigrant to
Britain radicalized in a British prison
the two Tunisians who blew up shah
massoud the leader of the Northern
Alliance on September ninth two days
before September 11th in what was now we
know in retrospect part of the whole
operation to weaken the Northern
Alliance converted in a Belgian mosque
we have a pattern here now what is this
pattern about why does it happen in
Europe well several factors are at work
here and this was certainly clear to me
being in Belgium this last week where
there are 300 mosques on 200,000 of the
million people who live in Brussels are
North African immigrants or their
descendants but the other thing that
really strikes you when you're in
Belgium as elsewhere in Europe is that
America is an imperfect melting pot but
we do aspire to be a melting pot Europe
does not aspire to be a melting pot and
all one need do is talk to young Muslims
in a place like Brussels to feel the
rage they feel at being stiff-armed in
effect outside of society these young
men and women gather together often in
prayer groups for warmth and solidarity
as immigrant groups often do some drift
into more radical ones and some drift
all the way to Afghanistan and al-qaeda
what fed this phenomena is that many of
these autocratic Arab regimes expelled
their most radical preachers where many
of them found asylum in the name of
being political refugees in a lot of
European countries
Britain France and Belgium in particular
these European countries did not take
seriously the most radical of these
prayer leaders and they were really
given free reign to spread their
ideology among some very angry young men
but I do think you have a third factor a
larger factor um which I can only put in
in almost computer terms and a reason
and it explains to me in part but not
completely but in part um why this
happens in Europe and this larger factor
is what i call the poverty of dignity
911 is not about the poverty of money it
is all about the poverty of dignity in
doing this film for the Discovery
Channel what is so striking is how you
hear when you talk to these young men
from from Indonesia to Cairo and from
Cairo to Brussels there is one word that
consistently comes up two words extra
say that consistently come up one is
dignity and the other is humiliation and
it makes a lot of sense when you think
about it when do you get mad not when do
you get mad but when do you get really
mad well if someone was in in the public
i can tell you when i get really mad
like fantasizing I have a bazooka on my
shoulder mad okay it's not when someone
criticizes you it's when someone
humiliate you or attempts to humiliate
you sameer call off a Lebanese
sociologist friend of mine did a study
of violence in Lebanon book called civil
and uncivil violence and what he
discovered is something very simple
Lebanese rarely killed each other over
divisible goods land money they always
killed each other over indivisible goods
honor respect dignity identity now the
reason I think this brew happens with
these with these Europeans
at work is these young men come to
Europe they are raised in Islamic
tradition and this is no no criticism or
slight to Islam Islam sees itself is the
most ideal and complete articulation of
the monotheistic Creed with the Quran as
the most complete and perfect
articulation of the monotheistic faiths
and Muhammad the Prophet Muhammad as the
seal of the prophets God's last
messenger and word on monotheism if i
were to put it in computer terms these
young men come to Europe with a view
that Islam is God 3.0 and Christianity
is god 2.0 and Judaism is God 1 point 0
what they confront in a very very
powerful way in Europe is the reality
that God 2 point 0 and God 1 point 0 are
living so much more prosperously so much
more powerfully and so much more
democratically than God three-point oh
and I believe this creates a certain
cognitive dissonance someone has to
explain this this mismatch and the
people who explain it are the likes of
Osama bin Laden it's very simple they
say that's because the infidels the
Crusaders and the Jews who always go
together in bin Laden's language God 1
point 0 and God two point O got together
and did something to or took something
away from God three-point oh that's one
explanation they offer and the other
explanation the offer is that the people
responsible for taking care of god three
point oh the current leaders of the Arab
world have corrupted and corroded the
operating system now of course there's
another explanation the other
explanation is that God two point O
isn't really got two point oh it's
actually got two point Oh point one it's
a Christianity that's gone through the
Enlightenment and Reformation embracing
modernity and separating church from
state and God one point O isn't really
got one point no it's actually got 1
point 0 point
Judaism that for the most part has gone
through that same process until and
unless there is a God three point 0
point one this cognitive dissonance is
going to exist for a lot of young men
and of course there is a struggle about
this within the world of Islam right now
over whether and who can or should
articulate a god 3.0 point 1 now what do
we do from our end and what do they do
from their end to encourage the
emergence of of this kind of updated
modernized view of the world that could
be transformative of their own politics
well we need to do two things the first
thing we need to do unfortunately is
bring to justice the people who
perpetrated 911 we need to kill those
people I don't like to talk about such
things in public but the fact is people
say violence doesn't solve anything
that's not exactly true okay there are
times unfortunately where violence
directed at people who basically want to
kill you for who you are is the only way
out and we cannot shrink from that
responsibility because the message has
to go forth for purely deterrence safe
that you come to this country and you
kill 3,000 of our brothers and sisters
and we will track you down if we have to
look for you in every cave in Tora Bora
to find you you will not do that and go
back home and chortle over it on video
on al-jazeera over a good Turkish coffee
but much more important than killing the
perpetrators is killing their bad ideas
that is the real task now there we have
a role to play and the leaders of the
Arab and Muslim world have a role to
play what do we have to do
well the first thing we have to do is be
the best global citizens we can do if
we're going to go stomping around the
world wiping out al Qaeda cells from
Manila to Kabul to Baghdad or wherever
bringing a critique to bear on all these
other societies we damn well better be
the best global citizens we can be and
what that means for starters is that it
is just not on to be saying to the world
there is a war on terrorism folks and
you're either with us or against us but
in the war for a greener planet in the
war against global warming sorry going
to take a powder driving my SUV or
Humvee that is just not on that is you
cannot claim okay to be in a war on
terrorism on the basis of some universal
principle of right and wrong and then
ignore the other universal principles
that other nations oh dear so I start
their second thing we need to do
particularly this administration and I'm
not here to do any cheap shots on
anybody I'd do that twice a week in my
column um second we need to do it is be
much more sensitive of how we talk to
the world one thing if you write books
after a while you become an expert on
critics I'm an expert on critics now
there are two kind of critics in the
world there are critics who criticize
you because they basically want you to
succeed and their critics who criticize
you because they really want you to fail
and they are dripping with contempt for
you now the critic who criticizes you
because he or she really wants you to
succeed that person you'll listen to all
day the critic who criticizes you
because they really want you to fail
well that person can't tell you the sun
is shining because you're just going to
close your ears and that's something
this administration hasn't learned
people will listen to criticism if they
if if we convey a sense that we are
inviting them into our future that this
war is about something transcendent
about something more than ourselves but
if we come to the world dripping with
contempt basically people will shut
their ears and you can't tell them the
sun is shining I'm glad at some level
that there are people in this
administration who know what world were
living in and we're living in a
dangerous world that's really important
they know what world were living in and
they convey that to the world President
did in his State of the Union just the
other night my question for them is do
they only know what world were living in
do they ever convey a real sense and
energy and vision for making it better
and inviting other people into it I'm
all for being a bastard but I want to be
a wilsonian bastard not just a bastard
third thing we need to do is make a much
more aggressive high-profile effort to
resolve or diffuse the
israeli-palestinian conflict which this
administration has basically taken a
powder on now for 9 12 months they have
basically taken a powder now you can
take the view this issue is exploited by
the air press you can take the view that
this issue is exploited by Arab regimes
the fact is it is an open wound that is
deeply felt by many many people and
there is simply no excuse for sitting
back with arms folded
and not making a much more significant
effort to defuse this conflict so those
are some of the things that we need to
be doing what do they need to do they
the leaders of the Arab and Muslim world
well the first thing they need to do is
take on Osama bin Laden at the
ideological level you see one thing
about Osama bin Laden he is not some
fly-by-night guy he is an authentic
character he has an authentically Arab
authentically Islamic retrograde vision
but it is authentic this is a guy who is
a Saudi millionaire who gave up a life
of riches to go live in a cave in
Afghanistan and drive out the Soviets
and unfortunately he later turned his
guns on the United States but he is an
authentic character to defeat that kind
of authenticity you need another
authenticity you need an authentically
Arab authentically Islamic progressive
message and the sources of that
progressive message are there in the
tradition but it needs leaders and
educators ready to draw them out and
articulate them and the fact is since
nine eleven George Bush has still given
more speeches about why and how Islam is
a progressive religion then all the Arab
leaders combine and why is that why have
they not articulated a progressive
vision because virtually none of them
are progressives and so it's a bit of a
fool's errand I guess to even be
expecting that they would do it what
they do instead is they expel their bin
Laden's they export their bin Laden's or
they jail their bin Laden's but what
they never do is take their bin Laden's
on at the ideological level and so what
happens is you have an ideological
vacuum that is actually filled by people
who are just like
less violent and slightly less radical
been bin Laden himself and that has been
the case ever since 911 so many people
have come up to me in the last year and
said Wow Islam that's a really angry
religion I say no i'm sorry i don't
think so i think that's really wrong but
you know what i do think i think a lot
of muslims are angry i think a lot of
muslims are angry because they live in
as a faith community some of the most
repressive societies least empowering of
their women and affording the fewest
opportunities for their young people to
achieve their full aspirations what is
religion is just a mirror on your daily
life it's going to reflect the objective
context in which you live and context is
precisely what we have ignored for the
last 50 years the context within which
people live their lives is everything
and here ladies and gentlemen I point
you to the second largest Muslim country
in the world second largest Muslim
country in the world is not Saudi Arabia
it's not Iran it's not Egypt it's not
Iraq it's not Pakistan it's not
Bangladesh it's a place called India
India has the second largest Muslim
population in the world after Indonesia
and there is one crying fact that stands
out from the year of 911 and Indian
Muslims have their grievances they have
economic grievances they have political
grievances we had Gujarat last year
they're real issues that they have to
deal with but there is one crying fact
that stands out from the year of 911 and
that is that there isn't a single Indian
Muslim in al-qaeda and there isn't a
single Indian Muslim in Guantanamo Bay
now why is that I'll tell you why I
think it is I think it's because the
richest man in India today is a Muslim
software entrepreneur as imprimi G the
founder of wipro
I happen to think it's because the
president of india today is a muslim i
happen to think it's because one of the
few mas i know for women demanded the
right to pray alongside men was in
hyderabad india because they were
empowered and protected to do so guess
what folks this isn't complicated give
people a context where there's a free
enough market for them to if they work
hard advance themselves where there's
enough democracy where if they have a
grievance they can shout it without
being thrown in jail and where there's
enough rule of law that if they have a
dispute with someone they can adjudicate
it without buying the judge off with a
goat and guess what they don't want to
blow up the world they want to be part
of it context is everything put Muslims
or Jews or Hindus or Buddhists in a
democratic context and trust me you know
you will get and bring the best out of
them and context is exactly what has
been ignored in the Middle East for the
last 50 years we have treated the Arab
world as if it were simply a big dumb
gas station and we cared simply about
two things that the pump was open the
price was low and in later years that
they be nice to the Jews just be nice to
the Israelis keep the pump open and the
price low and you can do whatever you
want out back you can do whatever you
want in your school's out there in your
newspapers in your mas in your education
and your politics in your jails do
whatever you want out back just keep the
price low and be nice to the Israelis
well we paid a huge price for that on
911 because what hit us was what came
from out back now people say to me
Friedman have you lost your senses you
want there to be an election in Saudi
Arabia do
realize what happens if there's an
election in Saudi Arabia they will have
a press that will spew hate
anti-americanism and anti-semitism they
will have charities that will give money
to the most radical rabid fundamentalist
groups and the most retrograde educators
they will turn a blind eye to terrorism
nurtured with in their midst well good
morning merry sunshine what do we have
now no no no I want there to be an
election in Saudi Arabia I want the
fundamentalist to win because I want
them to have to pay retail for their
fundamentalism now they pay wholesale no
I want them to look their people in the
eye and say my people we are not going
to sell oil and gas anymore to the
infidels because they're in photos that
does mean if you were planning to send
your kid to Yale next year that's not on
and by the way if you haven't seen
disney world yet you're too late oh
that's when we will trigger what we need
to trigger and that is not a war with
Islam but it is a war within Islam that
we have civil war in this country we had
150 years ago people thought it was fine
and dandy to enslave people if they had
dark skin we had a civil war over that
we had a civil war over that brand of
intolerance well there is also a strain
of intolerance out there and it's going
to need to be fought from within and the
only people who can fight it are Muslims
and if you want to see what that civil
war looks like if you don't believe it's
possible then I point to Exhibit B and
that is Iran that civil war is happening
right now in Iran the fundamentalist
took over they got elected they control
the country and they are now burdened
with that responsibility and guess what
the third and fourth generation that has
grown up under Ayatollah Khomeini they
only know two things these young kids
today I was in Iran
just a few months back they just know
two things first of all they've never
heard of the show he could be Cyrus the
Great for all they care they just know
they were born under the ho mania
revolution and they know just two things
that they've had enough democracy to
know they want more of it and they've
had enough Islam imposed on them to know
they want less of it and they are in a
struggle now for a new equilibrium based
on real democracy and an honored place
for Islam but not an imposed one and God
blessed them they will find it and when
they do the impact they will have on the
Muslim world will be a hundred times the
impact of the ho mania revolution root
for those young Iranians because they're
going to make it it's going to take time
because unfortunately there is this
corrupting factor of oil in the regime
because it controls oil can monopolize a
lot of instruments of force to keep them
down but it's a losing battle and you
know when I knew it was lost when I saw
a little wire story out of Tehran two
months ago which I wrote about and it
was Iranian students at an
anti-government rally and one of the
signs they were carrying was death to
dictatorship think about that phrase
this is the student movement that
invented the phrase death to America
that was the chant of the Iranian
student movement that owl stood the shop
death to America and where are we
twenty-odd years later now they are
chanting death to dictatorship that that
is so beautiful that is saying we know
where the problem is the problem isn't
in Washington and it's not in London and
not in Paris it's here with our own
rulers you know it is not an accident as
burner Lewis has pointed out that the
two governments in the Middle East that
are the most pro-american Egypt and
Saudi Arabia have the most anti American
populations and the government in the
middle
that is the most anti-american has the
most Pro American population Iran and
that's for a very simple reason people
in Egypt and Saudi Arabia blame us for
their repressive regime well there's one
thing Iranians don't do and that is
blame us for their government they know
it is homegrown and they're going to
home grow an alternative with a war
within and God bless them because when
they do and they will they will have a
huge and positive effect I believe
across the whole Muslim world let me
close with just one observation in honor
of the globalization center on
reflections on globalization since nine
eleven whether I've people have come and
asked me many times whether I've changed
any of my views on globalization since
nine eleven and I'm like a good academic
I never change my views but i have
learned some things about globalization
since nine eleven and the most important
thing i've learned is what a complete
mismatch exists in the world today
between the speed to which we have been
all wired together technologically and
the speed to which we've actually
developed the frameworks to understand
one another there is a complete mismatch
today we have been wired together that's
right it's your height from scary hope
it isn't hot air did it we've been wired
together technologically thanks to
satellite cell phones fiber optics the
internet in a decade but to develop the
framework to actually understand each
other oh that takes so much longer I was
in Indonesia last summer and meeting
with a group of Indonesian journalists
and dumped we're having dinner and one
of them
worked for noms old magazine the Far
East economic review a young woman we we
were just talking I forgot it was
apropos what but she said you know what
it's basically she said that bill
o'reilly on Fox TV he really pisses me
off so I said to her when you're in
America don't watch Bill O'Reilly she
said no no bill o'reilly is now part of
my Jakarta cable package Bill O'Reilly
with his whacked-out views on Islam is
right there part of her Jakarta cable
package he's right in her face now every
night and she's probably one of those
people emailing him angry mail that he
reads on the air right back they are
right in each others face
technologically but the frameworks to
actually understand each other those
take years those take travel and
education and reading and language study
you can't download those things you've
got to upload them the old-fashioned way
and the mismatch between those is so
striking to me in the year after 911
because it's now like we're all sitting
around the same dinner table Americans
and Arabs and Europeans and Muslims and
Hindus and booze were all around the
same dinner table and everyone's
shouting at each other and throwing food
and it's like you can't go anywhere in
the house anymore to escape the argument
and so what all this globalization is
doing is instead of promoting
understanding it's raising the world's
blood pressure and the place I saw that
most profoundly is with the lie that
four thousand Jews were warned not to go
to work on September 11 that lie is
believed by the vast vast majority of
the Muslim world today and what I would
meet young Muslims and old Muslims and
Muslim leaders even I'm afraid and they
would repeat this to be this lie I would
say
young man just stop and think for a
second who could have had the names of
everyone working in the two twin towers
who then could have figured out which
ones exactly were Jews who then would
have had all their home phone numbers
who then could have called them all on
the night before September 11 and by the
way could you name just one person who
was called and then they would look at
me and say the saddest thing but mr.
Friedman I read it on the Internet you
see because it comes wrapped in this
patina of technology people believe it
even more they have no idea that on the
on a good day on a good day the internet
is an open sewer of untreated unfiltered
information that on the good days it's
an electron version of the National
Enquirer that they don't know that but
mr. Friedman I read it on the Internet
that is really sad but it is really true
when I was in Indonesia on that trip I
ran into an American diplomat at our
embassy who told me she had been in
Milan in east java and seeing a young
boy riding a bicycle wearing an Osama
bin Laden t-shirt and a New York Yankees
baseball cap I didn't see this person
but i can tell you i see many like it
and it really is a snapshot of young
people in the world out there because
they can go both ways frankly they can
go both ways they wear the hat and the
t-shirt very lightly they can go in a
way of respecting and embracing some of
the things we're trying to do in the
world and some of our best values I
would hope and they can go the other way
it is our job to do what we can from our
end so that in more places on more days
more of those young people grow into the
hat and not the t-shirt thank you very
much